hello to roger thanks for joining us um
so two heavy losses with by-elections
the chairman of the party uh resigns at
half-past five in the morning and still
the prime minister remains in post it
would appear that whatever happens he's
invincible
okay well first of all i'd like to
express my commiserations with the
candidates um in both of those
by-elections they deserve better frankly
than what they were facing
this is clearly a massive vote of no
confidence in the prime minister another
vote of no confidence in the prime
minister
and
a
an honourable and responsible man would
be considering his position again this
morning
that oliver dowden the chairman of the
party has resigned i think is
significant
oliver is a decent and an honorable man
and he's obviously decided that he can't
go on trying to defend the indefensible
and i understand that
what the rest of the cabinet will do
because a matter for the rest of the
cabinet to decide their grown-ups
they've got to make their own decisions
but if more of them go then even mr
johnson
may find his position untenable
but they haven't gone um up until now
and as far as the letter the resignation
is concerned uh from oliver dowd and i
mean it looks as though he's taking
responsibility uh for what happened he's
the chairman of the party
it was him that was running the
campaigns
well you put this to paul scully and in
fact he commented on that that that
letter is excoriating if you read
between the lines
um he's doing the honorable thing and
taking his responsibility as the
person with responsibility for
by-elections
but this responsibility lies fair and
square at the door of the man in number
10 and he should be taking the
responsibility not mr darden or indeed
any other cabinet minister
well as you know uh mr scully said you
can't read between the lines you can
only read what's there and that isn't
what it says
i think you can read between the lines
and i think oliver dowden has made his
position certainly in terms of the
effect upon the membership of the
conservative party
very clear indeed
look the
west country i know very well um i was
my family actually come from originally
from axminster which is part of that
constituency
the west country are people are by
nature
liberals with a small l
what they've now translated into is one
nation conservatives
and it is that reputation
for honesty and decency and compassion
the one nation tory view
that i think the prime minister has
trashed and that's why i'm taking such a
strong stand on this because i believe
that we are actually literally fighting
for the soul of our party and i will
fight to that to the death
it's often been said that the prime
minister's support is a mile wide and an
inch deep
but nevertheless he is
remaining
in power what do you think
it will have to take for him to go you
talk you talk about other cabinet
ministers potentially going in to see
him um but there aren't any of those big
beasts that i was being told earlier
like michael hesseltein who will go in
and say
sorry old boy now's the time well if a
number of the cabinet members do
resign then as i said okay his position
i think would be untenable but if if
that doesn't happen it may not
um then we look to
the privileges committee in the autumn
if the privilege and it isn't if of
course they haven't reached the decision
but if the privileges committee were to
find him guilty of deliberately
misleading the house and suspend him
then i think that he would have to go
unlike the prime minister i'm not in
favor of changing the rules in the
middle of the game
but if we were faced with that situation
then i think the 1922 committee would
have to look at changing the rules and
allowing another no confidence vote um
that doesn't say we're not at that stage
yet we have to see what happens between
now and then
isn't it fair to say though that he is a
serial vote winner and when it comes to
the big votes he does always seem to
pull the rabbit out of the hat when it
comes to by-elections you know that your
party the conservative party has lost a
series of by-elections but then always
or as then subsequently won a general
election on occasion
when you were interviewing will earlier
um he made the point to you and i'll
reiterate this but that was 2019 we're
now in 2022 the world is a very
different place in all sorts of ways
we are facing
enormous challenges in terms of costs of
living in terms of fuel
ukraine uh we've got another huge
problem of johnson's making actually
coming down the tracks on monday when
we're going to be asked
to vote for legislation that effectively
will
allow the united kingdom if that's the
right word to breach an international
agreement
the northern ireland protocol
there are a lot of problems lying ahead
and i think it now requires a change of
leader
and a
good determined honest responsible prime
minister to take us through those very
uncharted waters and there contrary to
what will said there are
significant numbers of people available
any one of whom could do the job well
and we've had played this game before
i'm not going to name a name now
but i'm quite certain that the moment
that there is a leadership contest
a good new leader for the conservative
party to take us forward with
conservative policies tax cutting
policies
financial policies that will serve the
people of this country will take us
forward in the right direction
um you have spoken previously about
changes potentially to the rules
regarding the 1922 committee and being
able to
vote with a vote of no confidence for
the prime minister as thing stands um it
will be in place for another year so the
prime minister cannot be ousted by that
method for another year um
do you want to look again potentially at
those rules being changed what would you
say to graham brady who is basically the
shop steward
as i've said
unlike the prime minister i'm not in
favor of changing the rules in the
middle of the game
but if
the privileges committee were to suspend
him and if he were then to refuse to
resign i think we would have to change
the rules